I did want to ask you about because it's
in the news every single day and I know
this is a huge issue for you it's the
least funny thing to bring up in the
world but I think about Ukraine every
day just because it is such a big part
of the news and I know that this is
where your people are from yeah you know
is Ukraine and I watch follow the news
every day and I think we're watching
people love to armchair quarterback and
talk about how in the 19
30s and 40s you know we really should
have stood up to sure you know Fascism
and if I were alive then I really would
have stood up you know we really needed
to stand up to Hitler in 36 or 750 and I
really do feel like
we're seeing this play out right now and
when people are indifferent about it or
indifferent about Putin or in in any way
I think you understand that this is the
defining fight right now in the world
and
25 years from now people are going to be
seeing this as a very important outcome
for the world for the entire world for
the world yes correct yeah I didn't mean
to get all heavy but I just thought I
kind of felt like I I know this is
important to you and wanted to talk
about it especially with the way the
news has been unrolling no I appreciate
with Putin getting incredibly desperate
and back on his heels you know it's one
of these situations where I think
everybody wishes and it's
um
it's weird how this war is affecting
some people and and other people are
like it's just a war over there it
doesn't affect me and I understand that
because I look at most wars over there
and they don't affect me right
and I keep trying to go even if I wasn't
from this country even if I was had no
association with it you have to look at
this war as a defining moment for the
West in on so many I won't go into
politics but what this will do to China
if x person wins you know what I mean
like there's so many players here and I
was like so just look at it
strategically as like this is a very
important War not like should you care
about the people or the refugees like if
you don't have time for that I totally
respect that you're busy you have bills
to pay you got food to put on the table
I get it but just remember that this is
the the breaking point for whether or
not democracy lives or or will where
democracy falls on the global scale and
that's the only thing that I ask of
people like just keep reading the news
keep getting yourself invested you have
to do money or time I mean other than
information
that being said you look at what's
happening in Iran right now no one's
talking about that either because that's
not on the global scale right like that
what that that country is going to
handle that's not anyone's problem
because it's isolated it's not going to
trigger a nuclear war they look at
Russian Ukraine and the only when people
got upset like why is it why because
when it was popular I got pushed back
like I this is only popular because they
would give some BS reasoning they don't
talk about other Wars or other natural
disasters this way and I was like that
is true they should all talk about
everything that's happening but this has
not happened in a very long time since
the 80s where there was this fear of a
bigger problem yeah but I go back to and
I was talking about the women in Iran
right now or what's happening there
either so there's like a there's a part
of me that goes you can only solve so
many problems otherwise it becomes
overwhelming the idea of like how do I
help there what do I do there how do I
assist there what can be done it becomes
insanely overwhelming and so I think
that's where our Focus just kind of
naturally went to Logistics going back
to like logic like how do you deal with
things and as much as I want to deal
with emotion and take every kid in and
save every mother and go in there and
like give everyone a hug that's not the
best use of time or energy at this point
and so we try to solve problems with
logic so we try to go Logistics on
everything otherwise I would get
incredibly overwhelmed so what's the
logic and Logistics you use in in for
Ukraine Ukraine yeah you and Ashton
freezed a ton of money honestly we
wanted to be a data problem until the
governments step in because
realistically it Wars a billion trillion
dollar Solution by all means it's not
millions and so it was like 20 48 hours
in 24 hours in and we realized that
people were just not people kept call
people were just so confused to what
they can do right everybody people in
general as human beings want to feel
like they're a part of something they
want to feel like they're part of a
solution they want to feel good about
themselves they want to feel like they
did their job and it was showcased in
social media when it was like you know
repost this photo and that means you
stand with these people or turn your
profile picture into this and you saw
that people naturally were doing the
easy way right like if I click this that
means I'm for it so I made a difference
and I feel good about myself
so the thing that Ash and I wanted to do
was to make sure people felt good about
themselves because it does take time it
does take effort but also people want to
post it repost it and showcase it cool
we did this with covid with quarantine
wine where we were like okay how do we
raise money but also make people feel
people like they're part of something
bigger greater so we did it through that
and it was successful in that part and
so when we started this process we just
had to Band-Aid a problem and make
people feel like they're making an
immediate difference right so if you
were like hey give me ten dollars I'm
gonna go and buy a bunch of blankets and
toothpaste by the time I do all that
things will already be different 20
times over where the war is people are
super generous at donating so there's
tons and tons of warehouses full of
blankets and toilet papers and all of
the Necessities that are needed during a
crisis moment but getting it from point
A to B is always difficult and so we um
a part of this company called flexport
and they just do you know natural you
know they fly cargos right they fly they
ship cargo they're just a cargo company
there's a natural disaster in
um oh gosh I don't remember what was
maybe Puerto Rico but I don't remember
where it was and they pivoted and
started doing like an NGO version to try
to help because they realized that there
was and containers just sitting on the
side not being moved full of you know
blankets and all like the emergency
things that people need
so we facilitated that so essentially
what we did was we put point A to point
B with um with vetted ngos on both sides
that already had everything ready to
ship we didn't need your money for the
product we just needed your money for
the shipments that makes a lot of sense
to me because I think there's a sense it
can lead to apathy people I think most
people are good I think I think most
people are great I think Americans are
very generous people historically yeah
they do want to help there's just an
apathy that comes from is this really
going to get where it needs to be
exactly and you know I know I felt it
myself like I really want to help but is
this no one trusts anybody is this
happening everywhere right now like all
of the you know unfortunately all of
these big ngos the CEO is caught doing
taking 10 off the top or this Co is
caught stealing the money it's happening
all the time so I don't blame people for
not trusting or being tentative about
donating their hard-earned five dollars
ten dollars let alone a hundred or a
thousand yeah so we wanted to be super
transparent so we just kept posting
videos about it and then showcasing the
said plane going or the said cargo ship
going and so we're like this is what we
and we
um did an outline of like how much money
buys one flight round trip how much
money buys two cargo like we so you knew
exactly where all the money was going
and then the housing of the refugees
with airbnb.org that's already existing
right so it's using existing
infrastructure and amplifying that do
you have any family in Ukraine I have a
distant family we were the last of my
family to leave so we were 91.
um my family left I have to think about
it right after World War II so my family
was in the Holocaust right so the ones
that survived some left in the 70s some
stayed and then
um that was like one of the migrations
was the 70s and then the other one was
like eight late 80s early 90s right at
the fall and so we were right at the
fall but we were the last of my
immediate family to leave